and with the heartbreaking news of
amari's murder his maternal grandmother
is now talking to us
she says she learned of this devastating
news earlier today from her own father
after the boy's mother contacted him
madison kimbrough continues our team
coverage tonight with the family's
reaction
yeah mari's grandmother says she will
never be the same
after receiving the news today that her
only grandchild was reportedly murdered
a very hard story to report as the
conversation
was extremely emotional there's more
there's still too many holes
carrie howard the maternal grandmother
of amari nicholson
has questions of her own tonight
directed at her daughter
amari's mother why in five days did you
not video chat with my grandson on the
phone with me other
than friday night when we got from the
airport she also told eight news now no
matter the circumstance
it didn't have to end like this she had
my house she had two other people in
vegas that would have taken him so he
didn't have to stay with
terrell but in the end carrie howard
told us no matter what was happening
her daughter would not leave terrell
screw your clothes
screw all that all that can be bought
again tell us tell us you're in danger
and we'll take you
you know but nothing was said because
that's
that's where she wanted to be she loved
him carrie says losing her grandson is
the worst pain she has ever felt in her
entire life
as she will now look to the sky knowing
that amari is looking down
the only thing i can say is i know my
grandson will no longer be abused
he'll no longer be hurt and he can watch
over us from now on
and i will never be the same after
losing him
now taylor is cary's eldest daughter and
amari
was her only grandchild again this case
is still under investigation
so we will make sure to bring you the
latest details